satz und holt deiner mutter eine große
quattro voci hier ist kein geld mehr
drin dann zahlst du eben ich weiß du
hast welches
legen wir los
dort brice ist ein film über einen
einbruchsdiebstahl bei einem blinden
alten wehrlosen mann der dann
fürchterlich schief geht weil der alte
mann zwar blind ist und auch alt aber
eben überhaupt nicht wer und was dann
passiert dann kann man ein horror filmen
bzw
früher wäre klar gewesen dass es ein
horrorfilm ist als nämlich noch klar war
dass horrorfilm wenn ich einfach nur
schocks an schocks wein sondern wirklich
terror sie wirken müssen und dieser film
bewirkt terror
die scheiße halt nicht immer ein haufen
tschuldigung stehen bleiben
was hast du jetzt
das ist der hat in avatar von james
cameron 2009 schleifer und schlechter
gespielt
und hier legt er jetzt seine beiden
haupt talente nämlich ein
differenziertes darstellen von
bedrohlichkeit und große körperliche
präsenz in eine figur und diese figur
ist glaube ich eine der zeitlosen horror
heimsuchung also so ziemlich auf einem
plateau mit dem frankenstein ungeheuer
ruder leatherface aus texas chainsaw
massacre
auch wenn er gut ist nimmt sich die
gesellschaft vor in der sahara entsteht
und zeigt ihnen was was sie über sich
nicht wissen will und dieser film ist im
grunde in katastrophen- und apokalypse
film weil er zeigt wie verwahrlost und
verheert diese gesellschaft schon ist es
gibt einfach keine nachbarn mir
der kerl hat sein haus seit fünf tagen
nicht verlassen auch wenn er drin ist
gehen wir rein ich besorg als klar war
dass
in diesem haus spielen sich
ungeheuerliche dinge ab aber es
interessiert keinen und keiner greift
ein dann kennen wir aus der bildzeitung
und aus den sonstigen medien jede menge
solche geschichten von herrn fritzl über
das haus in höchster bis zu 2 und diese
wahrheit das sozusagen keine keime mehr
hilft und dass es eben gegen dann gibt
die schon völlig and mensch sind selbst
wenn da noch welche wohnen das ist die
wahrheit die dieser film dem horrorgenre
hinzufügt und das aller gruseligste ist
dass das zwar in die deutsch spielt wo
es diese viertel massenhaft gibt wo
keiner mehr wohnt und alles passieren
kann das aber gedreht wurde in budapest
das heißt die einschläge rücken immer
näher die das hollywood-kino für uns hat
man kann diesen film niemanden empfehlen
aber natürlich sollten alle rein gehen
also empfehlen heißt ja es wird dir spaß
machen aber der spaß ist doch mit
beträchtlicher unlust verbundenen hier
allerdings mit einer hausse die auf
einem kunst level stattfindet den man
sich nicht entgehen lassen sollte selbst
wenn man es gerne würde